hello everyone so this is me shupanta
dey a student of genetic engineering and
biotechnology at the university of
thakur i have currently been in a
research fellowship program in omixlogic
bioinformatics
dr harvitkov madam has been my
supervisor
so today i am going to show you the
project we have been working on
the research question is
how the third dose of malaria rdss1
vaccine is associated with controlled
inflammation and increased protection
for this we did bioinformatic analysis
on significant gene expression on
various stages of the vaccination also
we established a relationship between
the genes and connected them with
various pathways they affect
in 2019 there are 229 million malaria
cases and among them 409 000 states
occurred there is a continuous problem
with malaria and only vaccine can help
us if we think about the long-term
solution africa is the worst sufferer
from malaria if you look at the figure
at the right side the dark green areas
in africa has faced 10 to 40 million
million cases in 2015. other regions not
much less either
and in the other figure red regions
indicate
increase in malaria cases green regions
mean a decrease in the number of cases
and yellow means somewhat both
so
i guess you all understand why malaria
vaccine must be very significant malaria
vaccine development entered a new
milestone in 2015 as rtss became the
very first human anti-parasite vaccine
to pass regulatory examination
that is our malaria vaccine it has
significantly showed that it can prevent
malaria
now you must be thinking about two
things one how does this vaccine can
protect us from malaria and secondly why
are you mainly focusing on the third
dose i will answer them both
this vaccine facilitates several gene
expression which is associated with
protection also it reduces the
pathogenicity of malaria
this is how it helps in protection
and we analyze first and second
those data sets too but the main reason
we are focusing on the third because it
is the crucial one associated with gene
expression changes also literature study
pointed out hard vaccination increases
the protection established significantly
on top of that our study also focused on
both regulatory vaccination and delayed
fractional thyroid vaccination so it was
a better approach to focus on how these
dose
affects gene expression mostly cytokine
ones
here we are going to talk about the
method we followed we divided genes into
groups so that we can do differential
gene expression factor regression and we
say plot an h clust for visualization
purpose
we found out the genes which are
significantly expressed then we found
out the up and down regulated ones which
helped us to reach to a conclusion with
our study with the help of literature so
let us uh look at the data set and the
groups as you can see the organism was
homo sapiens and ironic analysis was
done also the sample source was vbnc
samples if you look at the groups you
will see from pre-vaccination state to
day of challenge or control human
malaria infection day there are total
six groups and the number of samples is
275. we also analyze data sets of first
and second dose and we'll discuss them
later on
this plot includes all the samples and
what does it actually show us it shows
the variation in expression of sample
groups we understand from this plot that
day three and day one as you can see day
three and day one
uh they are together
from other groups but not so much
different from each other
day 14 remains totally in a different
cluster here most interestingly day of
challenge is not here the day of
challenge that is not far away than day
of vaccination day of challenge and day
of vaccination as you can see one reason
of that might be over expression or over
cytokine expression is related with
negative impact or pathogenicity in case
of malaria so not a not an extreme
response on the day of challenge that
might be good
figures will show you how the sample
expression pattern of all the groups
changes when we compare between one
group to another group this is necessary
to understand several gene expression is
associated with protection and various
number of significant genes in different
groups could tell us more about a
correlation
moving on at this point we showed graphs
and plots that help us in understanding
variation in sample expression pattern
in this slide however you can find out
219 genes are significantly expressed as
you can see 2910 genes are significantly
expressed while we compare between
pre-vaccination and day of challenge
samples in third dose
here you can see the volcano plot
for all the genes and here is a heat map
for the top 50 up and down regulated
genes
and now these figures clearly show you a
distinction
the threshold was uh if they are less
than 0.005 p value less than 0.05 as you
can see it is mentioned here and log fc
follows uh less than minus 1 or greater
than plus 1. now why is this
an important step for our analysis well
now that we found significant genes in
different samples we can see how they
are associated with different pathways
and protection in our body
let us focus on the interpretation of
what we showed till now and an analysis
of the significant genes
here we did various ontology and patho
analysis in nbc the most interesting
findings from this was cytokine activity
their receptor interaction and
inflammatory responses in all of the
pathways or biological molecular
function
also literacy studies have found in
plasmodium falciparum malaria in
sufficient oxygen reaching vital organs
and excess relays of pro-inflammatory
cytokines might be associated with
primary driving force of disease and
death cytokine is associated with
protection as well as imbalanced and
over
production can lead to pathogenicity
malaria related anemia less supply of
oxygen to mitochondria also happens
because of over expression of cytokines
so how the vaccine protects us from this
double last sort we'll get to the
answers
cytogram genes are mostly down regulated
but as you can see here the upregulated
genes are mostly associated with
regulation of calcium ion dependent
exocytosis or voltage-gated calcium
channels
now moving on
we can see
here the genes associated with cytokinin
inflammation present in all three doses
well
as you can see in the first dose the
expression is upregulated on the day of
vaccination in the second dose it is
both up and down regulated as you can
see up regulation and down regulation
but in case of charge regulation
the expression just falls here you can
see it is mostly down regulated this is
applicable for all the cytokine related
important or significant genes moving on
we will show you a heat map of the same
here you can also see how the expression
pattern varies from one group to another
and this also shows you a clear
distinction
now
we saw down regulation of cytokine
associated genes after the third dose so
we feel the need for analyzing what
happens after the first and second dose
that's what we showed you in the before
slides
we found cytokine and inflammation genes
are upregulated after the first both up
and down regulated after the second
what do you gather from this well
antibodies are produced against the
antigen of vaccine as they are triggered
from memory especially after the later
doses also cell mediated cytokines are
less expressed which was not the case
after the first or second dose this is
one more reason why third vaccination is
so crucial as cytokine over expression
is sometimes called the driving force of
malaria related death here the
characterization of cytokine or
chemokine patterns produced upon
vaccination can even contribute to the
identification of biomarkers of hexane
response
our literature study also supported our
claims and provided us with an even
broad view on genes associated with
cytokine regulation in malaria infection
cxl 9 10 11 infp1 interleukin-12b or
interleukin 6 or 10 or found to be
expressed significantly in several cases
of malaria and might have other drugs
related to pathogenicity too we also
found the upregulated genes are
associated with malaria infection now
we'll move to the next slide to
summarize what we have learned so far
three doses of malaria vaccination
results in pro and anti-inflammatory
cytokines being expressed in a balanced
way and we have noticed that after the
third
third dose
cytokine expression was down regulated
now it is crucial because we have found
cytokine over expression in case of
malaria infection is associated with
malaria related death and it is mostly
associated with pathogenicity so
when this happens it results in
increased protection and decreased
negative effect of cytokine over
expression and it all contributes to
success of malaria vaccine also we want
to mention r21 vaccine as it is showing
better result but it is still has a long
way to go because the study took place
in a smaller region and more study
has to be done
now
you can see all the references we needed
for this presentation
so we have come to the end thank
everyone for listening and trying to
understand how malaria vaccination helps
in protection by influencing gene
expression thank you again